en el paso de torkham solían cruzar
diariamente miles de camiones de
mercancía pero como pueden ver ahora los
camiones están parados porque las
autoridades paquistaníes tienen
estrictas medidas para mantener la
seguridad y chequean cada camión y cada
mercancía para poder entrar dentro del
país
delio más de 15 años transportando
mercancías a los dos lados de la
frontera ahora es imposible un oficial
viene a revisar las mercancías después
te pide papeles y todo esto puede durar
horas o días una garganta clip
somos refugiados afganos nunca antes nos
habían puesto tantas restricciones para
entrar o salir pakistán hay gente que
necesita recibir tratamiento médico es
una cuestión humanitaria estos afganos
están esperando a sus familiares que se
encuentran al otro lado y llevan días
intentando cruzar las autoridades
paquistaníes han impuesto medidas
restrictivas para el paso de los afganos
al país y exigen un visado o tener
permiso de residencia y aún así en
muchas ocasiones
a la entrada